could be knocked off early and now
elizabeth played a very natural move
instead of playing the move h5 she's
prefaced it with knight f4 she's at
least just played 94 given the
opportunity for this trade and now crush
going into a deep dink realizing there
is danger here her championship could be
in the balance if she doesn't defend
well right at this moment back to you
guys
wow
a sharp game uh i've got that i've got
the position arena's position up on my
board
and of course it's always tempting to go
for those king side attacks especially
when they uh appear obvious
i love this knight on d5 and i wasn't so
i don't like knight
well it's a natural move there's nothing
wrong with knight f4 but i was thinking
to myself
is it possible that i might be able to
exploit the c3 square
the only reason that i don't immediately
jump into the c3 square is this knight
on a4 so even though i don't like doing
it actually parting with the light
squared bishop i think also was very
promising
from black's point of view look at this
nice knight on c3 your rook on a4 might
get into the game if for example you
played a move like queen d2 i don't say
this is the only move but first of all
you win your pawn back you could always
trade down here and once you've once
you've eliminated this b3 pawn that b3
pawn is captured guess what we've got
two connected past pawns in the center i
like this position a lot yeah i mean it
looks nice for the free for black yeah
and then that hvac i i didn't like
knight f4 so much even though
i'm sure black still has a really nice
game it feels like we could do better
right and i just
that was what was attracting my eye
to this whole bishop c6 conference it's
amazing how playing on either side of
the board is good for black that's how
nice a black compensation is like
h5 ideas or bishop c6 ideas it all looks
pretty sweet for the black pieces so
we'll keep a close eye on this game and
we're going to take a quick commercial
break and we'll be back for more from
the u.s championships and u.s women's
this could be the key round without
question
i'm feeling great to be back here in st
louis the u.s championship is my
favorite event by far you play
consistently strong opposition
there's no free games it's always a
challenge right from day one this is my
first year's championship it is my first
visit to saint louis as well and so far
i like it everyone is a grandmaster here
and everyone's most people who are
playing here have beaten me before so
it's going to be a very tough turn my
approach to chest as cliche as it sounds
is just to play as many good games as
possible i've tried setting goals before
and it all it does is pretty much sort
of constrict my play it's going to be
probably one of the last chances for me
to win
so uh
i guess my goal is to win coming into
this tournament you're always thinking
games preparation open it's middle game
tactics you want everything to be solid
but i'm still trying to be realistic and
just get it one game at a time my
emphasis in the game is to learn and
improve it's interesting to challenge
yourself and play stronger opponents and
that's definitely something you find in
the yes championship
i think it's maybe just the feeling of
being back in st louis again it's just a
really really pleasant feeling the
weather is great it's so you can really
feel that it's summer here it's not like
that in new york well uh this year
i'm really trying to win the tournament
i've come close many times so i think
this might be the year i actually win
the tournament each year i compete in
the championships it's becoming harder
and harder to prepare i just finished
with my law school exams two days before
arriving for the championship of course
i will try to win but i i have to be
realistic i didn't play like nfc
astronomers since last year's
championship i had a break from chess so
i will do my best i do what i can think
is that this is just one game i play
with them so
so it doesn't matter they might be
better objectively it's how how we play
the one single game so i want to put all
my efforts to do just the best i can i
really like it because it's really fun
playing against new people and i get to
make new friends
my goal this year is to play fighting
chess and not have a single regret with
any game that i play my dad said
he said play well
so that's what i'm going to try to do
not just to get lucky but to try to make
some good moves
and welcome back to the 2014 u.s
championship in u.s women's we've got
arena cross defending champion
seems to be on the ropes against alyssa
malaquina
yes and alyssa has been playing good
forceful chess ever since
she came with that surprise gambit the
blumenthal gambit
dropping a pawn for active piece play
and
everybody likes her position
uh and arena crush
under pressure i i ha i can't see the
times very well i'm 37 minutes for arena
crush and uh 40 for alyssa so
considering they still have 21 moves to
make time control
not a lot of time and i think we're
going to see that increasingly become a
factor
now we've got some action in another
game
sam shanklin and daniel naraditsky and
maurice has some news for us on that
well it looks like white went hog wild
crazy and he's about to get spanked for
it because
it seems shanklin is completely lost on
the board he was going to say that he
lost his mind because he sacrificed his
pawn on b2 earlier in the game let's
jump back to that moment after bishop to
e5 he played the move knight to d5 and
after bishop takes on b2 he played g4 a
wild move compromising his king and
after knight back to g7 he attacked the
bishop down bishop f6 and then he played
this quiet move king h1 trying to build
his position up before his intended next
move 96 f4 tucking his king away in the
corner so that he could go crazy but
cool and calm daniel naradiski dropped
back and after g5 nardiski played knight
to c5 saying wait a second your f4 move
has weakened your pawn on e4 what are
you going to do about that well
charge forward was the answer but this
was not respected by naradiski he played
the move knight to e4 and after bishop
to d3 this was not optimal nardiski
played bishop to f5 and suddenly the
center is falling apart and no progress
being made for white there are no simple
attacks going he took on d6 and now
houdini's saying just capture on d6 with
the queen and look at black's pieces
they're all fantastic every single black
piece is wonderful uh he's about to play
a rook onto the d-file
and uh all this plus an extra pawn in
the pocket you know what they say uh you
have comp i have compensation for your
pawn well that's what he's got here and
there are no simple moves to play it's
just it's just terrible position for
white there's no progress you can't even
look to find what white should do here
look at this king look at his paw
information
no question about it shanklin is just
shaking his head wondering what to do
next well it seems as though he has
taken on d6 so it's all up to naraditsky
who looks really calm right now to just
play queen takes d6 that movie has
it looks over
like over right
well in terms of from a positional point
of view definitely naradisky
doing great
also from the king position point of
view daniel's king much safer the king
on h1 exposed to all kinds of checks
i don't know what the computer valuation
is but i would say at least one and a
half to two pawns advantage for
neuroditsky in this game and also even a
time edge as well
not significant at this moment but
just a huge advantage
and uh sam
um
was way way too optimistic this looks
like a case of falling on your own sword
i might add i might add a line in this
position that is worth noting that it's
just
ugly to look at i mean after queen takes
d6 nardiski could play right now rook
takes b7 trying to get the pawn back
i don't think so knight to c3 is beasty
hitting the queen hitting the knight
hitting the bishop
and knight takes knight
doesn't solve anything because of queen
takes and everybody's hanging look at
all these pieces under attack it's like
everything is hanging
the whole cluster is under attack as a
matter of fact here houdini is only
giving black a plus six edge which means
uh a hundred percent this game is over
terrible position for white that means
he cannot regain his pawn in this
position and naruto see just captures
back
all the whole structure the whole
bone structure you know to me i think of
the pawns as the skeleton well
there's no skeleton left
all the bones have just gone especially
the
the center ones holding up the white
position black's going to win this game
right now if he plays just a couple more
moves correct and you can see in his
eyes he's thinking yeah
i think i got him i think i got him just
got to play the right move absolutely
well daniel noradiski in his second
u.s championships
out to pretty reasonable start i think
he's at 50 having won one and lost one
and if he could get a win today that
would really lift his uh chances of
being in the podium by the end of the
event oh yes indeed i mean
nice even plus one in this tournament
i've got a kamsky
great success yes regardless of the
result that's only going to be half a
point behind the leader yeah like i mean
unless london wins or jacobian wins but
uh so far based on their positions and
playing the black pieces the that's not
so likely so four points might be just
half a point behind the path well
remember what we were saying if we could
get a you know a clo if we didn't have a
clear runaway
uh leader that just was winning game
after game but instead he had a closed
uh
a close race uh guys like alexander
o'neil were real threats and daniel has
been playing very solidly he's looking
very good and brought back our key game
got a kamsky against alex lenderman a
lenderman
co-leader with varujacobian in trouble
lenderman did not play
the queen c3 moves or
anything of that nature he has just
played rook on f to c8 a double-edged
move he wants to make his counter play
down the c file but he is
dangling this f7 pawn as bait that's the
pawn that white needs uh to get at
black's king well he's probably planning
on dropping back the queen as a defender
now instead exactly but i'm thinking
that
uh a a
a
little crafty move this move rook to d1
preparing that if you drop back with
your queen well thank you very much i'm
just going to take this pawn and my
knight on d4 does yeoman's work it not
only attacks your rook it defends the
nice c2 square and the knight is
dominant in the middle of the board so
you can't drop back with your queen
right away in the meantime with the
remove rook d1 i'm covering
i'm protecting it rather well i'm
protecting famous chess writer said i'm
protecting the pawn so that i'm
releasing my queen to
uh to go after the d4 pawn i see
i mean uh
lenderman may just be in one of those
positions that even if he plays all the
best moves
the defect in his position these double
d pawns is so great that even with her
beautiful play perfect play he may be
unable to save the game
so that would be a huge
uh
step for god kamsky and his efforts to
try to retain his uh u.s championship
title now meanwhile our other big
favorite pre-tournament alexander
arnoshop
having some difficulties against correa
we were looking at that position before
and you thought that ownership might be
close to busto unless you found really
perfect defensive moves right right and
let's go ahead and uh see how that's
going it doesn't seem like
ownership is too happy
i mean maybe it's just the lighting but
he looks extremely red in this
yeah the probably is lighting but this
uh posture of alex i've played him a
couple of times
um
and one time i had him dead to straights
and he when he gets into that uh
double-fisted uh
fist-to-cheek uh posture it's it's a
tell actually i'll just put it that
simply when we had left it
lots of questions about
ownership's position rook d4 this knight
on b2
misplaced
shattered kingside giving white a
wonderful opportunity to get at black's
king let's see what ownership did bishop
c5 rook g4 with a check giving up a lot
of tempos but
he perhaps felt that his bishop on a3
was vulnerable
so now he went back to e7 right 94 well
one of the nice things that uh onishuk
has done in this particular case is by
driving the rook to g4 he has given
himself a retreat square for his knight
knight e4 attacked the bishop
bishop dropped back
and now
knight
came to d6 so this carries with it a
threat of
rook b1 followed by knight takes c8 and
rook takes b7
gaining back upon with interest
right again uh what
jen is saying is if
white ends up playing rook b1 and
capturing that bishop then this pawn
will be vulnerable so knight d6 but was
knight d6
that's a
hmm
after knight to d6 ownership did play
immediately knight to d3
and now
the move when knight takes e5 is in the
air as well with the cat well first of
all the knight on b2 was really uh in
great danger of ending up being rounded
up
uh so knight to d3 bringing the knight
back in the game as you mentioned
the pawn on e5 defends the knight on d6
so knight takes e5 is on black's agenda
and that's right and in this particular
position there's no great in between
moves because knight takes f7 is held by
the knight on e5 meanwhile knight takes
c8 allows knight takes f3 with check and
then we would end up netting an upon and
an important part of that
okay so let's uh get rid of this uh rook
this threat pardon me
of knight takes e5 with the move rook d1
i'm supposing the knight just quietly
drops back to c5 and now white's got to
ask himself
with this bishop on e7 that pawn on h6
isn't as vulnerable i was hoping from
gary f's point of view that
white would generate more threats
against black's king and at the moment
he's not doing that something wrong here
i was sure that
that white was going to have more in
this position after
uh gary f played rook to
you
i don't like rook g4
i don't like a lot of things about this
position
i i'm not so sure about this move rook
g4 because
okay it won a tempo
but
somehow it released
the momentum i i don't know exactly how
to describe it but
rook g4 doesn't feel crispy
i'm going to have to turn this over to
maurice and ask him if
houdini was 100 happy about rook g4 it
just doesn't feel crispy to me maurice
please well yeah actually it's houdini's
number one move
position
okay so i don't know how crispy your
crispy gets right but uh it does say
that rook g4 is the only move that does
not get into a worse position in fact
slightly worse for white so it says rook
g4 check was correctly played king to h8
and now it also gives knight e4 as the
correct move bishop to e7
and it also gives knight to d6 as the
right move and knight to d3 so
the players certainly did their job
analyzing quite deeply to find this
position
and to play it
like a computer
i might
add i just want to jump to another game
that was important for us to be looking
at is this game between crush and
malagina remember that move knight f4
the move is
houdini's first choice but we were
talking about other possibilities and
houdini had other options here as well
for black knight f4 wasn't the only one
queen a5 check as you mentioned yes is
also another interesting move here and
at first it had given it knight f4 it's
its main
backing
but now
that knight f4 has been played and i've
seen computers do this i don't know why
maybe a
a viewer can tell us
after knight f4 landed on the board even
though it was his first choice bishop
takes it for rook takes f4 houdini got a
chance to sort of inspect this position
and as it's inspecting it's going
this is not as much as i could have
gotten out of this game and now when i
go backwards to this position it's
saying forget about knight f4 play
something like h5 or queen a5 and that's
what it really wants to do here this
knight f4 move was logical but now the
number three choice is thinking h5 was
the right way to play it's endorsing uh
instead she played the move knight at
four and after this trade but now she's
played a wild move g5 in the position
staying crazy uh this kind of chess is
definitely melojina's style but i think
it might be over the top you asked
playing a move like this one maybe more
than the position deserves but she's
going after this pawn i think she's
playing the position
mainly after the e pawn which shows a
fundamental misunderstanding of her
advantages the reality is the pawn
doesn't matter she's not down a pawn i
mean in your mind you think you're down
upon no
she on factually she's down upon on the
board but it's the compensation that
justifies what she's done and she's
playing like she's down upon the great
tiger and petrossian used to say or said
one quote that i've loved ever since
reading it he said
players sometimes sacrifice
upon and play as though they lost upon
so in this case trying to win the pawn
back at all costs and making moves that
mathematically win the pawn back
you sacrifice the pawn forget about it
it's dead it's off the board play like
you sacrificed it go for activity open
lines aggression she's playing like she
really wants that pawn on e5 back to
justify her play and i think that maybe
she's overreaching that's why she put
the knight on f4 trading a great knight
on f on d5 for a horrible bishop on g3
and now playing an even more committal
move in g5 and i think that irina is
going to be relieved to see this kind of
play on the chessboard
guys
and alyssa has been taking her time also
i mean i think she must have spent about
a half hour in the last few moves wow
slowed it down that quote by tal remo
reminds me of so many memorable quotes
uh that came out of the soviet era one
of my all-time favorites was the quote
that when
michael bodwinick sacrificed upon you
thought carefully
and then accepted it
when michael tull
accepted the pawn you accepted it
immediately and then you thought about
it when tiger and petrosian
sacrificed upon you resigned
your positions busted
tigger and petrosian sacrifice exchanged
he wasn't big on sacrificing the pawns
uh always uh
there's some more so many wonderful
quotes that came out of that is a good
option yeah i know um
let me just uh go back to the gotta
kamsky game uh for a moment because that
that that crafty
veteran move rook d1 was in fact played
by
and
it's always nice when you're when you're
planning an assault against your
opponent's king
that you see a move like queen b6 i
don't want to criticize this move and
say oh this move is awful or anything
like that but i'm just saying that as an
attacker you like to see your opponent's
pieces on the other side of the board
and this is an open invitation for godda
to go queen f4 not especially since
black was probably preparing to play
rook c2
first of all queen out with tempo you
you dodged the threat as you just
mentioned of rook to you so you you step
aside from the tempo and you're again
eyeballing this pawn on d4 so you can
take a pawn very
nice gotta say purchase
but this is the move that's really
getting my uh
eye catching my eye is knight g5 and
forcing that rook back
back to f8 and tying up your opponent's
pieces so that maybe you can play rooksy
one i really like
the way ghada has handled this this is
more or less a dream
quick check on the clocks because on my
screen the club 30 minutes for
gotakanski and
lendermen so i don't think this time
will be an issue in this game that much
because no they do only have 14 moves
till time control although these moves
are going to get quite critical
absolutely i think that in the women's
championship is where we're more likely
to see some some craziness in that
respect because uh
i read a question by the king i've only
played half the time control right now
just one quick criticism of mel
melakina's move a g7 g5 that she did
play
um
everything is fine for black she's got
the two bishops her rooks are great
her king very importantly king position
as we know as an element in chess and
whenever we're attacking we'd love to
have a safe king
having said all of that there's only one
piece in her position that's not
working at maximum efficiency and that's
the queen
so black's queen on d8 is the issue here
and the move queen f8 queen f7 queen g6
or queen f8 queen f5 get the queen into
the game please
and this move g7 g5
um like you were saying like what
maurice was saying in tigran petrossian
she sacrificed upon
for an initiative and now she's playing
like she wants her pawn back desperately
and obviously her idea is to play g5 g4
and go after this pawn on an e5 but that
should not have been her
choice she should have just activated
her queen right i think it's hard for
sometimes tactical players they're
thinking and tactics trying to regain
the material and
sometimes the whole logical part of your
brain where you're just like wow that
knight on d5 is awesome
he like shuts off a little bit it's
harder to access and then after the game
or if you move later you're like wow i
miss that guy oh yeah like what happened
here the problem that i see for melakina
is that after a move for example like h3
if arena plays h3 and black really goes
whole hog with h5 first of all her king
position is going to be dreadful after a
move like knight e1
to capture to trade this pawn on e5 for
this pawn on f5 followed by knight d3
this whole idea of knight e1 knight d3
is really uh suggestive and i'm sure
arena
was very happy to see the move g5 well
inside arenas played 91 immediately
not not trying to provoke h oops i've
darn it i closed the wrong screen i
apologize
uh she's played okay she wasn't she
didn't try to
i thought you make h2h3 lift you try to
provoke your pronoun to play h5 but
she's played knight e1 immediately
looks like a very solid move by the way
you put your knight on d3
that's really nice good blockade
attacked the rook defend the pawn
and g5 was just
wrong it's a pity because uh
elisa had played really terrific up to
this moment
and maurice what are your thoughts on
the developments in crush metallicana
yeah it's sad you know you sacrifice a
pawn for an initiative and then you get
greedy or scared maybe for the pawn back
there's no question about it that arena
crush feels great right now and houdini
justifies that feeling as well that
sentiment that black playing this move
g5 exposing the king
used to be black had a decent paw
structure the only thing that was that
was comfortable in fact about the pawn
structure was the fact that there was a
pawn on g7 obviously black's pieces are
a little bit funny but this bishop with
a beautiful diagonal it had there was a
knight sitting on d5 such a great piece
so unfortunately alyssa has thought
about the position the wrong way and
this knight headed to d3 as yas said
beautiful place for the piece to be on
and also on top of it alyssa had a clock
advantage as well but now she's at a
disadvantage by about five minutes more
than five minutes now as a matter of
fact so she's really fritted away what
she had in this opening she's gonna kick
herself for not playing it correctly we
shouldn't be too hard on however her
opponent happens to be a five-time
champion uh grandmaster so she
not expected to play perfect moves i'd
like to bring your attention to a game
we haven't looked at in a while ramirez
friedel and this game we saw a crazy
piece sacrifice as well and it's settled
down now into two nights against a rook
and it looks like two nights against a
rook and and two pawns well he can pick
this pawn off right now so it'll be five
against six
the computer here likes white uh i can
understand why at least right now this
king looks like it's never going to have
a permanent home that's safe no matter
where it goes and these rooks have a
straight file to work with and of course
these knights do not impress the only
issue there for ramirez is that he's
used time in this game he's at 18
minutes and 56 seconds and one game we
did not look at at all i'd like to point
out some funky tactics happened
in the game between nemkova and his
waron this position had been achieved
and just quickly to point this out
eswara on the 13 year old played this
move bishop to b3 the reply queen c1 and
then this tricky move bishop to d5 of
course the knight cannot capture on d5
because there's a nice little fork that
could happen in the position there so
knight takes d4 however now uncovering
an attack on the bishop the youngster
played this move and was met by a
counter in between move knight to e6
forking her rook and queen with a threat
to this rook on f1
esquaran thought queen c8 would not be a
problem actually she had to move queen
to d6 as well but they would both have
been met by the move nimkova played
which was knight takes c7 again leaving
this rook hanging but she's hitting a
rook and getting out by taking the
knight on b6 so eswaran had to take here
and the game
after king takes g2
black has lost a pawn in that
that complication
uh going back and forth so right now
eswaran down upon and trying to figure
out how to save herself looks like the
youngster is in trouble in this game
back to you guys wow i love those
desperado tactics you've seen them in a
couple other games in the championship
as well as an english player i'm very
familiar with those types of tactics uh
of 96 and knight c7 and stuff and swaron
needing some experience i mean this is
her debut
u.s championships
women's
but
that was an experience when she went for
this whole tactical sequence that
maurice was
going through i'm sure the move knight
e6 and knight c7 took her a little bit
by surprise calculating it's definitely
the heart of chess and with that we're
going to be right back stay tuned for
more for the u.s championships in u.s
women's
so
do
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the 2014 us championship and u.s
women's championship remember guys there
is a rest day tomorrow so as much as you
love watching these players duke it out
and
yes and more recent my analysis of the
struggles you are gonna have to miss out
tomorrow
um
let's take a look at our puzzle so today
we're showing you more fisher problems
here we've got fisher versus ross limo
another position from the u.s
championship
we started showing you these in honor of
fisher's
11-0 score in the u.s championship 50
years ago and they were so popular that
we'll show gem after gem that's right i
think we've got a long time with bobby
fisher and maurice ashley has the
solution for you guys
well as you see there the move bishop
takes
f5
yikes i mean it's not everyday you get
to play a move like bishop takes f5
attacking everything actually one move
before is the position you see on the
board he started with the move knight
takes e6 setting up the killer blow
bishop takes f5 now rossolimo had one
little prayer small one and he hoped
queen to c4 check
now white has two ways to handle this
check by moving the king and uh also
another way by moving the bishop back
and maybe he was praying that fischer
would have pulled the bishop back
somehow and allowed this discovered
check
and after pawn takes he gets a queen
no that's not going to happen
after queen c4 check also king g2 would
fall for the same night fork fisher just
played king g1 and looked at him and
said really i mean look at this lineup
along
the h3 to a to c8 diagonal totally over
busted easy crush and rossolimo decided
all right you're right i've had enough
so another gem by fischer small moves
the guy was all about just winning the
way you ought to he always liked to find
the best move and this he did here in
this epic game
guys
now speaking of bobby fischer we
mentioned that he enjoyed playing the
king's indian attack as white and so
let's move on over and see how his
king's indian attack is progressing
against alexander lenderman who's been
leading the tournament if he can win
this game
it's going to throw everything upside
down and
uh what's going on now what a prayer
works was traded i i've been riveted to
this game of god of camps
versus uh alex lenderman they're having
trouble tearing us away exactly
uh we got to this position and um
pardon me we got to this position and
gotta play this nice little crafty rook
d one move queen settled back and queen
f the queen g5 making his intentions
very clear
i want to come in to
queen e7 square and followed up with
knight g5 and by the way there's a pawn
on d4 constantly hanging
queen b4 was played to protect the
square e7
and then gotta played rook d2 and said
okay i don't want to see any rook coming
in to the second rank
because by the way if
black could ever win this pawn on a2
then this pawn on a3 would be huge so
gotta cover it up a little with the move
rook d2 now we need that we need to have
the check because if we had played rook
c2 instead then worked
afterward takes you two or takes you to
queen d8 jack would be devastating right
so again uh one of those ready-made
checkmates
checkmate to go
ready-made checkmate i like that because
that's a marcel duchamp reference really
he was the famous one
the toilet in the art exhibit that was
called a ready-made because it was
already a piece of art all he had to do
was sign it
oh really he also did the bicycle wheel
right yeah
ready-made art exactly and there's
actually a chess set of his ready-mades
now to people listening now that might
sound ridiculous but at the time it was
really revolutionary because it's not
the kind of thing that art students all
over the world were doing it people were
like
couldn't even believe that somebody
would think that that was art and so he
was really opening people's eyes up
conceptually to what art could be
wonderful lovely and tomorrow he we're
going to play his uh musical chess board
which
every square you me every time you make
a move um it releases a note or a tune
now in the original match where you
played john cage in the musical chess
board it was supposed to be extremely
boring because they would think for a
long time and it was actually just one
note
so very john cage like that you would go
to a concert and you'd actually just
hear a note every five minutes or so
tomorrow it's not going to be worrying
though i don't think tomorrow's gonna be
a little bit different and here's
particulars if any of you guys actually
it's sold out but
you can watch them online which is
awesome isn't that awesome that sold out
but you can watch online and you can
also uh i think they're gonna live
stream it on the third floor of the hall
of fame as well
um so the reception starts at six and
the concert begins at seven
and if you can't attend you can enjoy
the show on live it's going to be live
streamed starting at around 6 55 and
maurice yasser and i are also going to
be involved in this and we're going to
be
making music on the chessboard making
music so check it out um but speaking of
making music on the chessboard
how did we get in this conversation
something about godakovsky's great play
here and rooks c2 the ready made yeah
so the queen
knight f8 would lead to queen f6 and
queen f8 would lead to just queen takes
knight
so that's why he had to choose rook c1
instead of work c2 because at least now
it comes with the check
and black has a moment to figure out how
to deal with these threats
either by retreating some major piece
basically
well exactly that's the problem that
black has is he's got to keep constant
watch over the f6 square you just can't
allow white to creep in and deliver the
checkmate queen f6 to g7
uh queen d a check is a big threat
at the moment if alex were to pull his
queen back
to defend against queen d8 well then
after
knight takes d4
he's down a pawn
and
the play is going to revolve around
whether or not
white's attack on the queen side
pardon me white's attack on the king
side is going to come through so for
example after knight c5 there are some
counter chances going on here but i
still have this
impression that black's in deep trouble
you can play a move like 92 just kicking
away the rook of the rook where could
the rook go let's say the rook could go
to uh the b1 square just for a moment
how else can i get in there
d4
not
exactly what i wanted
hmm where can i get and if c2 doesn't
doesn't quite work because you can
always just like take on d3 and
everything is just guarded
and you're just in time to uh stave off
the checkmate
by attacking the part on h6 so
god is going to win a pawn i don't think
that there's anything that black can do
about that
um
but i i'm just
i i keep looking at these ideas oops
excuse me after knight to c5 after night
to see if i keep you know trying to
figure out
can i
set up mating attacks like this i want
to go check and i want to go queen f6
check and mate
um
these attacks look very very dangerous
for blacks and that's why we're keeping
such a close eye on this game because
it's kind of like this amazing
combination of positional chess with
tactical chess right so mostly it's a
positional squeeze but then gotta is
gonna pounce just when it's most
devastating and that's what's so fun
about watching this game
unfolds yeah so maurice ashley is gonna
drag us away from this game something
about us we just can't keep our eyes off
of it and maurice what have you got for
us on crush of elekina you know i like
the crazy positions you guys just like
the solid squeezes uh but i think you're
going to be entertained by this next
variation take a look at this
it looks as though an arena crush versus
melikina alyssa milikina that crush has
made a mistake after we came in at this
position 91 crush seemed to have a
pretty nice position even though it's
it's not overwhelming at all by any
means and as a matter of fact uh this
this position seems like it's okay for
black it's just black has
made a concession that she did not have
to make in the position
here she went and struck on the correct
plan of bringing her queen to this side
knight to d3 rook to h4
at least this plan was good before there
are other moves she could have made here
but let's not get into those in this
position though
her rook going to this strange square
didn't want to back up and get chased
around into a bad square but she got to
this square and the right move here
believe it or not is g3 now that's a
risky looking move because there's
sacrifices on h2 and a queen check
coming here i'll just show you that line
pretty quickly that you would have to
avoid uh thinking that maybe you know
you'd have to navigate but it turns out
that this simple move bishop to h5
defends the position there's no danger
this bishop on h5 is solid and white's
just winning white's upper rook instead
of doing that move
irina played after this move rook h4 she
decided to play bishop to g4 attacking
this pawn first so now the move bishop
to d5 was played
and it turns out that in this position
it's not so easy to continue the main
point now check this out is if the move
g3 it's possible to sacrifice this
exchange on this side
and then sacrifice an exchange on the
other side and suddenly the position has
blown up because after the move c4 this
knight has trouble moving because guess
what this knight is going to take on e5
attack this queen so where can you put
the knight first of all it can't go
anywhere here because it's hanging it
could go here for the moment the point
being that you can't play pawn takes
knight because of that pin but
black just continues with knight takes
on e5 so a double exchange stack one on
one side one on the other kicked the
legs out from under the night and once
the night moves now a knight's coming in
here and where do you go
where can your queen hide it is no place
to hide as a matter of fact because
there's always going to be some kind of
funny disco or you're losing your night
disco meaning discovered attack or
you're losing your knight because the
pin is no longer on plus these two
connected past pawns so it turns out
there is some potency in the black
position that white has to be careful
for so irina may have made a small slit
by putting her bishop on g4 intake right
now and she's studying the position
trying to figure out what she should she
should do next and the time is beginning
to take down for both players
irina with 20 minutes a five-minute
advantage
versus 15-13 for her opponent but it's
become complex now and alyssa milikina
is showing that she has fighting spirit
and a good understanding of the tactics
in these lines back to you guys
so we got discos and rovers and all
kinds of things going on don't we and
some upcoming time pressure was such a
hectic position in fewer than 20 minutes
on both sides
and by the way that exchange sacrifice
rook takes g4 you know
we saw a possibility for alyssa to
sacrifice on the exchange on f3 earlier
and get great comp i think she should
have gone for that
at the moment though
a very sharp position both players have
it to play carefully
a key game also in our men's
in our open section
the co-leader of aruja nakobian playing
against the young
webster student ray robson
ray has finally kind of thrown out
an attacking move here we see in the
last position
knight went to g5 bishop dropped back
and now this queen on a1 that has been
tucked into the corner went queen b1
and what ray is trying to do is he's
trying to set up all sorts of sacrifices
either against the f7 pawn or against
the e6 pawn with his bishop so for
example one possibility
is to sacrifice a piece like in this
fashion king going to h8 i'm sure the
the computer will say black is fine
but you know the queen coming over from
b1 to g6 is the type of thing that ray
is looking to achieve and getting a
an attack going against a koben's king
again okobian our tournament leader
having defend with the black pieces in a
sharp position as well a position that
had been
quiet has gotten sharp
29 minutes for varusian and we've got a
result in sam shankland has resigned
against naredinsky wow that game is over
maurice ashley
indeed a scintillating finish in this
game the youngster showed his stuff here
in this position first of all he was
already up two pawns uh well one pawn in
this position but you could count him as
three or four pawns his pieces are so
fantastic white had no coordination
whatsoever sam's going to just say he
lost his mind this game because after
knight to e7 challenging the only
kind of one only good piece in wise
position knight takes on e7 rook takes
on e7 and black's pieces just keep
getting better and better the move queen
f3 was played and after rook to d8 now
the knight had to grovel back on the e1
square but black understood his
advantages he continued to exchange off
pieces with bishop to d4 and a trade and
now knight to c2 he might have been in
time pressure i'm not sure when he
played this move but it certainly didn't
help after queen c5 now rook to b5 and
without question now i'm i'm going to
guess the move was
played and it and it was played
beautiful finish uh knight c2 queen c5
rook b5 he found the winning sequence
first an exchange sacrifice with rook
takes
obviously your queen is hanging so rook
takes queen just just runs into rook
takes queen let me get that analysis
board for you
rook takes queen just runs into rook
takes queen here with a check threat and
your rook is hanging so that's a
meaningless line so here after rook
takes d3 queen takes d3 now the night
fork knight check and after rook takes
no way black wants this guy although
that's probably winning as well
but instead the nice move queen c6 check
hitting the queen and now the game is
over because you have check on the king
and if the queen tries to save itself
either on f3 or d5 bishop to e4 check
that's a nasty way to win a chess game
great win by the young player poorly
played by white for sure but black grand
master naradiski showed how you punish
this kind of loose play back to you guys
great victory by the young danya and we
expect to hear from him soon he's
getting set up for an interview shortly
um it's great to see that the first uh
the first game finished in
in this round of the championship is a
win and a win for black at that so it's
going to be a bloody round just before
the rest day tomorrow and with this when
danya brings himself into plus one i
believe
uh putting him right there
in the group of the leaders our u.s
junior champion
uh remember acquitting himself very
nicely
in the first
well it's past the halfway point but if
he keeps up this kind of play he's going
to be a force he could be a contender
for the u.s championship this year
without question now in ghana kamski's
game he did play uh
for
bishop to h3 so we just started shooting
h3 in another game and now we're singing
it in kamsky's game as well so we saw
robson playing for surveillance
to kind of target the e6 pawn so both
robson and kamsky playing uh
similar moves in their games against the
leaders right so i'm i'm trying to uh
guess uh the concept behind the move uh
bishop h3 because gambling on bishop
takes c6 right because uh knight takes
d4 it looks very
natural of course to
win upon
but
gotta felt that getting his
bishop into the attack
and
eyeballing this pawn on e6 if if you
could play knight takes d4 and knight
takes e6 and there is a
disco
in the position that when this rook on
d2 does move there is queen g
pardon me queen g5 takes c1 tactic there
so bishop h3
right bishop h3 is a
small little move that could have could
leave a very big impression if black
doesn't get any activity uh white's
going to win this pawn on d4
and just bringing his
pieces into great
squares where he can sacrifice on e6 for
a crushing attack well the big problem
here is that i mean yes we didn't take
on d4 right away but how do you propose
to defend that pawn queen c5 would be
the only way but that queen is busy
taking care of business queen a
protecting against queen d a check right
so exactly so just uh actually knight
takes d4 you could play anyway after
queen c5 right you want to show that
uh
as pardon me
five yeah queen c5 well first of all it
does depend upon on d4 but then again
that
ready to go checkmate right it always
appears
check
and that was what we were talking about
i do why why that pawn on h6 is so
there's no rush to take that pawn on d4
no
and in fact he probably wants to take it
at the right moment so the knight takes
e6 is an even more brutal threat exactly
and we've got grandmaster daniel
naredinsky
with another victory and increasing
himself to a plus score at the u.s chess
championship he's with maurice
indigen the youngest male in the
competition
playing fine chess to this point grand
master daniel naradiski welcome to the
show and congratulations on your game
now this game it looked like he was
trying to just blow you off the board
this was like caveman chess just hack
away and see what happens but you just
took what he gave you and rebuffed the
attack yeah i mean i was pretty lucky
and that this was still preparation i
actually looked at knight d5 at home i
managed to predict that he was you know
he was in an aggressive mood so um
yeah it was how'd you do that
i mean i looked at e takes d4 i i
knew that you know there was a about a
95 chance that there would be mainline
kings indian and uh knight c2 was a
pretty modern sort of interesting move
that's been played uh recently with
great success for white and actually
knight d5 has been played like four or
five times in grand master games and i
think white has scored a astronomical
percentage because black you know if you
don't know exactly what to do here it's
very easy to to lose oneself
but i i looked at this pretty pretty in
depth and i felt really comfortable wow
so here you took the pawn yep and he
played g4 did you anticipate that yeah
g4 is still okay quote-unquote theory um
one game one f4 but that's just too much
giving up the rook so knight g7 yeah
rogue b1 and bishop f6 and i realize it
looks really flimsy for black but uh
oh okay
houdini and and i did not really or more
like houdini he did not see did not see
a very convincing follow-up for white
and after f4 i think
yes he actually played king h1 okay h1
yeah so f4
is i believe the main move
uh
yeah rugby on bishop f6 f4 and then i
was gonna play knight e6 and it's really
complex but i think black comes out
uh black easily holds his own against
white's attack you know it's scary but
it's
i think it's uh feasible for black so he
went after you with the idea of f4 yeah
and then you played uh bishop dropping
back yep and then he went for g5 and
then you played this move the critical
test knight to c5 and it looked like
right here everything went wrong for his
position yeah i mean he he's advanced
response his position is really flimsy i
mean his center is really weak and i
thought there's no way that this could
be um
sound
and certainly again it was pretty scary
to face this sort of pawn armada on the
king side but i figured
at this point i
was almost sure that i had a clear
advantage and houdini agrees with you
after e5 you centralized your knight and
then he played bishop d3
bishop d3 is another mistake i mean
bishop f3 he has some chances maybe but
of course my have a vicious counter
attack in the center he eventually i
think the center will collapse
it looks like it's collapsing already
i mean i was calculating bishop f3
instead of this uh bishop f3 if you
don't mind pressing oh sure yeah oh wait
let me get rid of this
first bishop f3
uh bishop f5
rook takes b7
and uh i actually was planning to play
knight a5 perhaps it's a mistake
according to houdini
it's its third option here looks like
you can just take on e5 yeah perhaps i
can i thought d65 knight take c7 wasn't
clear but okay i'm sure it's
it's it looks really dubious for white
so that was an alternative for him he
said he played the move bishop to d3
and now after bishop f5 his position now
crumbles yeah really fast as a matter of
fact he took 26 is important yeah
because rick takes seven knight c3 and
it's uh yes
we pointed that out in a broadcast this
must have felt really good today
like this yeah it's like everything is
defended i'm just about to launch into
a vicious attack and i could see that of
course game's not over until it's over
but um
i just couldn't even find any way for
him to resist well walk us through the
rest he played rook to b3 defensive move
and you decided to kick the legs out i
think that's an accurate move because um
you know i don't have to hurry i can
the knights is only pride of the
position you know if i get rid of the
knight his position is just a jumble of
complete and total weaknesses so indeed
not coordinated where these pieces the
knights did get traded off he played
this move you brought your last piece
yeah no hurry just want to increase it
and increase it and then when i do go
into the final invasion it'll be much
stronger indeed and now he played 91 you
played bishop d4 again trading off maybe
what looks like his last good piece just
positional and uh
yeah without the dark squared bishop
it's you know it gets even worse
classic chess indeed after takes takes
and now he played knight c2 queen c5 did
your eyes light up when this movie was
good i played c5 i saw b5 originally i
was worried because after rook takes c3
this line uh queen takes c3 knight f2
check
yes
originally yeah rook takes f2 and
originally i thought uh i have to go
queen takes f2 and i'm winning and then
i saw queen d8 check
and i thought whoa let's be careful here
and i was pretty much
elated when i found queen c6 check you
know it's yeah that's a nice little one
to be able to play the king we're on g1
it wouldn't have been
right indeed and he did move his king
off to that squad he ended up hurting
him
wow very nice win uh now you're at plus
one
which is an amazing place to be at this
stage considering you lost the game
earlier in the competition how are you
feeling about your chances going forward
uh i'm feeling great uh i think i'll
sleep easier today you know it's it's
always good to come into a rest day with
with a nice win on the previous day
once again the tournament is only
entering the most important stage
everything can change because the field
is so tightly packed and everybody's so
strong and etc uh but of course it feels
it feels amazing to win two games with
black against you know very decent
opponents and i'll just try to keep it
going and keep playing in the same
aggressive style
well keep it up we enjoy watching these
kind of games and we wish you the best
in the rest of the tournament thank you
the youngest in the field grand master
daniel naradicki showing his stuff and
his very nice understanding of how to
prosecute an attack
yes this is entertaining stuff back to
you guys oh it is great stuff it's a
combination of very very good
preparation
daniel got just the type of position
that he had been studying working on he
knew all of the themes of the position
and everything just played itself let's
get right back into robson
because there's actually a pawn
sacrifice alert there isn't there
absolutely i've got it up on my screen
might be a little bit quiet but
it is instead it's blown up and
black has grabbed the pawn and white's
compensation in the form of two bishops
well let's just go back a few moves
because we were pointing out that after
this bishop
came to h3 there was some
opportunity for me
for white to sacrifice on the e6 against
the e6 pawn thanks to the bishop on h3
so var
uh droitly defended the clan on e6 with
knight f8 as well as defending the pawn
on h7
so
oops i i went too fast i apologize
uh we're back here
um
also by the way with the defensive move
knight f8 the bishop on d4 was under
attack
uh rook came over to d1 h6 knight f3
bishop f3 gf3 queen f3 i think we're up
to date on the position with ray robson
white to play he's sacrificed upon
and it seems to me that his
best opportunity of of showing
compensation is to play the move knight
to e5 with the idea of trying to bring
the knight to this nice square knight c6
um and i think he just played that move
knight e5 first of all it's always great
to get rid of your opponent's queen with
a gain of tempo so 95 picking up a tempo
against black's queen now vara is going
to have to make a key decision here
if he just tries to retreat
his queen on the diagonal he's really
encouraging now the bishop to come back
to g2
again i don't think
um
vara wants to give up control over the
c6 square so he'll have to block with
the knight he's a pawn up
but i do think that this position with
that beautiful bishop on g2 does give
white some opportunities for example
here the knight can come back to e3 to
get rid of that knight
but there ought to be some
i keep looking at these sacrifices
knight f7 bishop g7 i can't make him
work yeah you're trying to get your
queen into the game somehow but the
thing is right
the bishop on age three was also nice
because
some variations there was knight takes
f7 coming in
but you know that night on f8 hard to
get mated when your opponent's got a
knight on f8 well that was uh the great
quote of benton larsen stick your knight
on an f8 and you never get mated and
that is what akovian is channeling how
but hey we predicted this game would get
interesting despite a slow start so we
were right about one thing right well
all the games had well not all the games
but certainly the godokamsky game also
had that slow build up start but it
looks like
some really nice attacking chess being
played here in the seventh round and uh
one game that is certain to blow up
crushed melakina both players not a lot
of time on their clock and piece is
flying wonderful let me bring marisa i
think has something for us in that game
wow yeah that game has blown up
officially it's going crazy all right
this position of course you see a move
like g5 rook on h4 this kind of wild
pawn structure just disconnected pieces
something bad's got to happen you got to
keep control in this position crush
played the move f4 and after f4
well actually yeah this was the moment
we had it the move f4 was played and
here melahina played the move queen h6
hitting the pawn on h2 can't let this
breakthrough happen and after the move
h3 she took on f4 and now preparing to
bring her bishop to the g5 square and
there's some complications for white to
maneuver here she played the move queen
to e2 and now bishop to g5 did happen
actually the computer likes king to h8
more keeping this pawn under defense but
this move now bishop to g5 is on the
board the position is crazy white has
regained the pawn but it looks like this
pawn might drop but position is not so
easy because if you take this pawn
the move f3 is on tap check out the rook
on c1 hanging as this pawn attacks the
queen so the position's crazy now crush
has nine minutes she had an edge
remember a five minute edge now she's at
nine minutes and 43 seconds melahina
with 10 44 and they have to make 14 well
make that we have to back up two so it's
moves after this move bishop to g5 15
more moves to go with only nine minutes
on the clock and an increment of 30
seconds per move she looks like she has
indeed made her move now
and she played bishop back to f3 and in
this position
the move that the computer is
recommending is c4
getting wild here you cannot take with
the pawn obviously because of bishop
takes on f3 and then this knight is
hanging to that rook so
guess what after c4 houdini is giving
the move
rook takes on c4 and after this capture
a capture on a8 and
who knows what's happening probably only
the computers this one is crazy and we
are definitely going to keep our eye on
it guys
wow thank you for that maurice uh
very sharp tactical battle what had been
a
what arena had wanted to do was keep
control over the position limit it
limit the tactics but she has failed uh
in that attempt to do so and we've got
some movement in the uh kamsky lender
game so
um after
bishop to h3 rook c3 knight takes d4 and
now i'm wondering
how lenderman's going to deal with this
direct threat of knight takes e6 picking
up a couple of pawns i'll come to that
uh
gen right away i just saw one other
tactic that i wanted to share was that
in this position
uh the computers move bishop f3 and c4
and and all that wild and crazy stuff
maurice was mentioning this the
sacrifice rook takes a4
in a similar type of position and the
idea was
after the rook is recaptured then you
just want to play c5
c4 and and have these really powerful
uh connected pass pawns in the center on
the c5 and d4 square
this too is a wild
exchange sacrifice i haven't looked at
the tactics deeply i can just imagine
that after bishop takes d5 e takes d5
white arena gets in her past pawn as
well i don't know what's happening shall
i go to gotta camps
while you pull that game up we've got
another result in ramirez for dell
maurice what happened in that game it's
over
it's totally incredible what happened in
the game because we thought white had an
edge in this position but black won and
won easily as a matter of fact take a
look at this after this position we had
we thought that the knights were not
very good and maybe the rooks could
double on this file and get an edge but
instead
ramirez played a sub-optimal move he
played the move f4 and after queen to b6
a queen trade was forced and suddenly
the knight particularly this one had
block hating squares where the rooks
would never be able to get in and from
this point ramirez needed to find
to realize that he was actually in
trouble here because the rooks have no
way in the move f5 comes to mind maybe
swinging the rook around didn't matter
though because after rook f3 knight to
c6 rookie 4 and now knight to c4 and
suddenly the black knights are just
entrenched in the position he's still in
the game but he did not play it well
this night maneuver going back the rook
showing up on this square now knight
over to g6 g3 and give me a first pawn
he must have been in time pressure here
because he donated excuse me after h4
donated a second pawn in the position
and after h5
what do we say about that knight on f8
you may not get mated you also can hold
the whole position together now the rook
has nowhere to go and black's just for
choice here he tried to bring his king
in did ramirez but after c5 trading off
pawns there went a past pawn running
down the board b3 king d2 rook to b7
getting behind the pass pawn c6
attacking the rook i don't care give me
that and here comes the girl you queen i
queen ramirez played one more move and
then looked at the position after he had
just made time control and realized that
his rook was still ridiculous that this
guy had a queen and a pass pawn still
and
a very bad game for ramirez as a matter
of fact he's going to be kicking himself
as well now we've seen two players with
white shankland and ramirez go hog wild
in a critical game
that's not how you do it meantime komski
is showing how it's done don't rush
just keep driving the car you'll get
there eventually
not here in these games but we do have
two victories by the black pieces guys
excitement in the round right before the
rest day black drawing first blood in
two games that's absolutely incredible
no trolls yet either um so kamsky
lenderman lenderman's still thinking how
do i deal with this knight thanks e6
threat
now
you know you might need to bolster you
either need to defend the knight on d7
or you need to bolster e6 right those
are the two options right the last move
by godakamsky was finally the d4 pawn
has fallen and knight takes e6 followed
by bishop takes e6 is what white is
planning on i'm thinking that you got to
play knight c5 even if it does give up
this f6 square in many variations um
and actually a move has been played
okay so the variation i was just looking
at was something very funny like b4
knight takes d4 b5 with ideas like queen
uh e3 trying to take advantage of the
pin i think god is very close to winning
this one
and instead uh leonard has played a move
he's played king to h
after knight takes d4 king to h8 yes
king to h8 on the board wow and now we
have to consider the ramifications of
sacrificing something on e6 perhaps
knight takes c6 or
bishop
it's hard for
you to hold everything together for
instance bishop e6 pawnee 696
queen g8 queen e7 looks very promising
for the white player certainly
attractive so what jen is saying is
bishop takes e6 f takes e6
knight takes e6 picking up a tempo
against black's queen black has to keep
in mind that queen e7 queen deater
scintillating threats um so queen eight
would seem to be queen g8 would just
walk into the queen queen e7 so queen e8
looks box yeah as we say only move now
there is not the threat to capture the
the knight right away because i've got
this queen d8 check but uh
the problem white's having is he needs
to get his rook into the game to really
uh load up or we could just play like
1970 67. okay you want that that's a
nice idea just get it how often do you
see that knight on g7 for the win
exactly some pretty interesting play
here and i i think that pawn is pretty
hard to stop
but uh we've got unbeatable
we've got another winner two in a row so
this is all about the twitter alright
version twitter now grandmaster josh
ferdell with his lucky hat he is with
maurice ashley
indeed
we're with grand master josh fridell
first of all congratulations thank you
you got two in a row how does it feel uh
pretty good um i mean a couple days ago
i wasn't sure whether i could win a game
at all and now all of a sudden it's two
in a row so i'm like huh it's getting
easy well
let's not push it
we didn't think that you had a great
position coming out of the opening and
all of a sudden you traded queens and
everything was fine yeah uh well it was
one of those things where i thought i
was in
the i hadn't looked at this particular
line recently um
it's a little bit of a new opening for
me and i hadn't looked at this exact
line so i thought that i was remembering
something and i was calculating and all
it was all good then all of a sudden i'm
like wait a moment
something's something's different and uh
i was actually worried i was going to
lose in like 15 moves or something when
he sacrificed on g5 if you may yeah
please bring that up on the board and
move 13.
uh
yeah yeah right there yeah i mean he has
to take i think right you did you
calculate queen f3 and the whole i
calculated all of it and then i remember
this 98 move it actually there's a
variation that i studied that was very
similar to this so i thought that this
was it but then all of a sudden i'm like
wait this is something's different and
uh i was really you're talking about
after these moves queen f3 the computer
like king d7 here but i thought bishop
d5 was very strong then
right but
bishop d
king king d7 let me put that on the
board
new variation
bishop to d5 i think knight takes e5 was
his yeah i looked at this but i thought
it was pretty terrible uh whereas i
thought the knights versus the the rook
had at least had some chances yeah
but i was i was very uh upset with
myself at this point because i thought
that okay i could just lose i mean it
was very careless
um but i guess but after 98 maybe bishop
takes e6 is inaccurate uh which was a
little surprising
uh because here i thought that he could
at first i thought that bishop takes e6
wasn't even playable because of rook b8
but then i really see it just as bishop
takes f7
and if if uh knight takes f7 queen c6
check and all of a sudden i'm just
losing by force so
um but after bishop takes e6f takes e6 i
think it's maybe not as clear but yeah i
mean it's it's not surprising that i'm
in trouble here
uh but i think maybe i'm not sure
at this point i think it was very tricky
but i thought queen a7 maybe yeah i
expected rook 8z1 and then rook takes d4
and i thought
okay i mean maybe i can survive but it
looked kind of sketchy but
queen a7 so rook fate's only move i
thought uh so the trick is that if queen
takes c5 rook takes f2 and he can't stop
me from checkmating him
um
so yeah i mean we we uh we saw the way
the game concluded it was really fine
style the way your knights came in
your score is now at even um plus one
plus one even so you're chasing uh the
leaders right now how does that feel um
you know it's an unfamiliar position in
this tournament but
i'll you know i'll hopefully i'll get
used to it
well i'm i'm sure you will you got a
rest day to really get used to it before
coming back to do battle congratulations
on your win and we hope for the best for
you in the tournament thank you very
much grandmaster josh friedel winning
two in a row and back in the hunt at the
u.s championships back to you guys
i think that's a nice pattern zero four
draws two wins so i think that it's just
another two winners yeah
keep keeping keep the ascending going
extension going you know what you were
absolutely right on crush melakina it's
blowing up and she played your exchange
sack rook takes a4 c4 on the board
both players with about five minutes on
their clock you couldn't ask for more
excitement out of this game wow i could
l let me see that clock again i i know
irena's thinking now after c4 so
deciding what to do with her knight
or whether to throw one bishop takes d5
well actually that looks impossible
because it just takes on d3 right
well yeah that's not so clear yeah
there's too many tactics there's a lot
going on right
just to go back to this uh exact moment
again you look at this formidable force
of these uh
pawns on c5 and d4 and you say well how
can i really improve them this knight on
d3 is a great blockader this pawn on b3
is in the well is in the way look you're
giving up a minimal exchange sacrifice
but you're getting these two high-flying
past pawns you're attacking the knight
on d3
if the knight has to retreat i'm not
saying it's force you may end up wanting
to play bishop d takes d5 if the knight
has to retreat
um
boy just looking at it and just doesn't
leave a good visual impression it really
doesn't after d
four d3 you've got you've got a
potential for d3 d2 and if the queen
goes to a bad square i'll just choose a
bad square
knight takes e5
and
black's crawling all over white this is
certainly not the position you want to
play in time pressure though i think you
could say that for both players maurice
what do you think wow this is impossible
to play in time pressure you've got to
be like magnus carlsen or hikaru
nakamura to
be able to weave your way through all
the complications or you might want to
be houdini as well if you're that then
you could do it too because houdini is
saying in this position that
black is busted
black's just busted uh the right way to
play here is to make this guy the only
piece on the chessboard is the pawn
there are a couple of moves one move
that's the most logical to me it has
bishop d5 it's his first choice but
they're very close uh in this moment to
keep the position under wraps just play
queen b2 donate this night don't worry
about it just take and have this
position on the board the point being
that these three black pieces are stuck
in place so they're not really going
anywhere but this guy's fast and you're
just going to run this down the board so
at the simple cost of a night if you can
just keep the position locked up
maybe you will have a chance and more
than just a chance this apon is trying
to go down the board and make its
presence felt so that's what's happening
right now according to houdini but
a human sitting at a chessboard forget
that this one is really complicated
because when we go back to this position
after c4 what you see is your knight's
hanging and pieces are swarming so let's
see whether or not arena can get out of
this position
well it looks like you played knight to
b4 and then after d3 we see queen b2 on
the board and now how does alyssa
continue that that queen on b2 defends
now the pawn on e5 ah so alyssa played
bishop to e7 so now she's trying to
creep in with the bishop
on the long diagonal the g1 a7 diagonal
which could lead to some interesting
tactics on h3 right so bishop c5 check
king age one would lead to
way ahead of me
after night before the night was the
very human move night before by the way
i'm also a very strong move
according to houdini that move according
to houdini's winning on the spot as well
which is which is pretty crazy since it
wasn't its first choice but it's saying
that this move is crushing the night
before d3 another very human move you've
got to get your past pawns uh pushed and
now queen b2 happens
sidestepping the threat of uh and
protecting the pawn on e5 so this knight
can't get back into the game and sorry
what was it so bishop e7 happened
so she's trying to get that bishop
rerouted to a diagonal and irena snapped
on d5 with the knight yes yes
this is the position on the board
and now crunching guys that's supposed
to be horrible now for black black is in
deep trouble losing critical pieces and
that's in this line the attack is gone
it's the attack's just dead and the
fantastic bishop has disappeared from
the board
so bishop to c5 check occurred and now
it's irina on move and we don't think
she's going to allow king h1 well
actually now the queen is uh still on
this yeah
so queen h2 but anyway king h2 is
probably what you would play and this
does look crushing i must say we have to
go back a few moves because i
wasn't so sure that this exchange
sacrifice was that bad but i think the
follow-up in this position after the
move queen b-2 i think this follow-up
bishop e7 was just wrong this knight
bishop takes rook takes
um
oh boy it's still not no i don't have i
don't have the peace the piece
coordination i need here at all my
maurice is absolutely right my three
pieces on the king side are all kind of
muddled up i can't play queen g7 and
knight e5 in the line i wanted to so
let's see
what actually
has happened
uh looks just over for
black
i got it right yay
king h2 is has been played and
now these pawns are dropping
everything's dropping it looks terrible
for uh um malagina
and
that means that irena will will likely
uh go into the lead because ana zatanski
bahrainskaiti
um even though obama's not having a good
tournament she seems like she's
availing herself quite well against
datonski um both of them are in time
pressure but the position is rather
simplified if you want to bring it up
okay in fact camilla seems to have
for the better of this playing against a
very weak pawn on d4
you're not playing a nice little end
game over she just played rook to d5
rook to d5 i was about to say white from
white's point of view white would like
to play moves like d5 and knight c
fought knight c3 pardon me so rook to d5
was played thinking about playing rook
to a5 and it's black who's going for the
win here and white's gonna have to
actually defend
yes but because the position's so
reduced
is it
that bad i suppose it is it's just
simply very nice position and what are
the times of the players the times are
very low for both players three minutes
and one minute but of course they've got
12 moves to play but it is pretty
simplified so i imagine they'll be able
to make the time control so a4 with the
idea that rook a5 could then be met by
knight to c3 clear
and so um camilla just calmly brings her
king into the game will this be enough
for her to win or will ana successfully
defend well we've seen her defend
a poor decision poor position earlier in
the tournament against victoria knee so
i too
like her chances to defend but of course
it's definitely black on top here
yeah but again
there's no material uh
i mean
it's equal material if white could just
play king f2 e3 and knight c3 all of her
troubles are over she'll have her own
pass pawn as well i suspect
we're still closer to draw than to the
win
but
anna will be
unhappy of course that she'll be half a
point behind arena going into the free
day in case of a draw in this game still
all three results are possible but i
agree uh camilla is in
good shape at the moment that's right
and so
losing steve a little bit here zatonski
with the white pieces what else do we
have going on in the women's
championship maurice
well it looks like the third woman in
the championship the third ranked woman
in the championship tatev abrahamian is
steamrolling to a win right now just
quickly as everybody else is in time
pressure in this position against sabina
foser she had managed to get a strong
bishop on this diagonal and she milked
that position after king to g8 not the
best move here she played the move rook
to e6 after queen to d7 now knight h4
trying to get into the position on the
h7 square clearly but the only choice
was something like rook fe-8 that would
have been worse for her dropping a pawn
but this way of dropping a pawn is
miserable knight takes f5 queen to f7
she thought maybe she had a chance here
but she's not really attacking the
knight so queen to e2 was played and now
she's played the move knight to c7 and
it looks like a combination tactic
somewhere has to be in the position to
kind of move we would see in one of the
combination books and how would you do
it here simply rook takes on g6 is
devastating clearly queen takes is not
playable because of knight to e7 royally
forking the pieces and the other
variation
here pawn takes
also drops to knight e7 check and you
pick your poison how you want to get
captured on g6 if the king goes here
there's knight takes with check if the
the king goes to h7 there's bishop takes
i mean it's just miserable this game
should be over any second abrahamian
surging forward looking for a full point
in this game and looks like she just won
a piece cleanly after the sacrifice and
or did she sacrifice i'm not sure
looking at her board
it looks like she did sacrifice indeed
she she played no instead she just
played knight to e7 check and after
knight takes rook takes
on e7 but isn't this just winning
uh after queen takes
that looks like a queen takes queen
rook oh whoa wait a minute
queen takes rookie eight
there must be a tactic here yes help me
out uh bishop bishop oh maybe you might
start with a check on it at least
checking on a2 should work out in the
end
because you can take the knight and be
up a piece minimum
oh yeah that's exactly what the computer
is saying bishop a2 check works and
after the king moves then simply queen
to b4
and
that's the end of that story so tatev is
going to win this game easily in this
position
rook versus queen
and tatiaf surging feuzer wonderful
start 2-0 just having a
horrible time in these last four rounds
things just haven't gone well it's like
the wheels fall off and she's in a what
did you call it tilt chest
situations people tilt in chests as well
so version of cobia and he's surging
upwards and i'm starting to look at his
position and think hey you know he's uh
consolidated here well first of all he's
a pawn up white has the two bishops
there's no knight c sixth threat so for
sure var
our tournament co-leader in great shape
against ray robson as his king is
incredibly safe just like right 40 knots
over here a lot like you were looking at
some lines where you thought that white
had some compensation knight c6
with the rooks on the boards and stuff
like this well now it seems like ray's
gotta be regretting sacrificing that
pawn or or you know losing that pawn in
some way or the other well this sounds
like a round where white's over optimism
you know white keeps falling on a sword
and good defense is beating good offense
black is okay today yeah black is great
and uh and well there is one one notable
exception we definitely like kamsky in
his game against lenderman but
there's been some switcheroos in that
game we thought that maybe kamsky would
try to sacrifice to bring home the point
instead he's just tried to consolidate
his extra pawn
and we've actually seen his uh his
pretty knight disappear from the board
that being said
he's up a pawn up upon and
and he's holding all the important
squares from the hook
and the real problem is this night this
night at the moment really is not
helping black's cause you swing this
knight
it's going to take you a long while to
get there if you swing if black
if alex could successfully put his
knight on b4 then he's got compensation
uh
most certainly but in the meanwhile look
at this white has these nice little
creepy crawly moves with the king goes
to g2 rook goes to e3 rook steps to f3
and there's a bishop takes e6
yeah a slow rover
uh
it's like it's just the
attack f7 right
and build up and and concentrate your
focus for the whole game really exactly
so upon more
good position good attacking position
actually forgotta uh he's cruising at
the moment although i did think that he
might just break through immediately
it's just like it's going to be a slow
grind well you can never be that
surprised by the word slow grind and
kamsky can you and maurice what do you
think about this game well he took it a
bit too far actually he had a chance to
end the game now houdini's saying he
only has a small edge well a little bit
more than a small edge we certainly like
white's position here for all the
reasons you pointed out yes but you
would have liked white's position even
more if he had sacrificed on e6 because
this was crushing if he had captured i
mean clearly winning a fat pawn a
critical pawn in the position and after
knight takes this position
you have to judge that it was winning
but here's the deal you just back up and
there's nothing to do the positions just
busted this e6 move is going to win that
piece back with no problem and then the
dangers of getting onto this diagonal
would start to show one move we should
point out is queen takes on e5 but
clearly that doesn't help because of
this check so the pawn is definitely
immune and also knight takes e5 doesn't
work because of queen to f6 check
followed by queen g7 mate so there's
actually no defense
after knight to f4 which which might
look like um not the move you would play
your move gen knight g7 looks more
natural
although it looks unnatural but it goes
forward with the knight to go backward
with the knight and say buddy i got you
there's nothing to do about e6 that's
the bottom line rook to c8 could be
played as a variation but then e6 and
you're just going to give the piece back
and be down pawns and this would be an
easy mop-up operation so komsky missed
this simple sacrifice that would have
led to an easy win but i'm sure he's
confident that his technique will have
him win now especially since he's got
258 to his opponents 130 they still have
to make time control here so let me see
exactly what move number they're on
looks like they're on move 35 so five
moves to make 147 left
for lindemann with 30 second increment
i'm pretty sure they'll make it we'll
see what happens in the next few moves
that's right we got a couple of quick
moves coming from them
gotta komski's were treated with queen
to d2 right um and after queen d2 and
lenderman's going after your plan of not
rerouting the knight via b8 to b4
perhaps right and so he played knight to
b8 and gotta quickly responded with b4
perhaps anticipating that plan and now
if
knight to c6 he's got
he he can play
b5 himself perhaps so instead
players are playing quickly by the way
they are
moving right right along so that's right
after before
um quick rook c4 by lender man
oh after b4 rook c4 was played yeah rook
c4 not knifed not not i was thinking
that maybe the point of before was that
after knight c6
right and uh and god actually played b5
anyway anyway exactly after rook to c4
got it and now uh lenderman to play
lenderman to play about a minute and a
half for two moves
okay actually three mm-hmm 38 39 40.
too much
some chess players you don't forget they
they see white's 40th move they're like
okay we're good no no no no no no no no
you gotta make it
found out about that the hard way one
time
do you know i was so called cruel to
hikaru of course you're referring to
that famous incident
uh in bilbao where
he was playing against the spanish
player
pons
and
he hikaru thought the 48th move had been
played he was black
and he asked the arbiter if we made time
control the time the arbiter is not
allowed to give information to the
player so the arbiter
uh claims that he didn't answer and
hikaru thought he
saw a nod
understood that time control was made
went
to the
uh lounge and
poured himself a glass of orange juice
came back and he was forfeited and i
think this forfeit cost him 30 000 euros
so what did yas do
yes i asked ikaro
uh how did the orange juice taste
this has to be the best tasting orange
juice in the entire world because it
cost you thirty thousand
must really like you you're saying that
he did first of all he did laugh and he
said that unfortunately he'd gotten that
joke as well like others said
has been played 1937 has been played so
um lenderman had dreams of putting his
light on b4 instead he's settling with
the d7 square which he's kind of been
struggling with all game right yeah that
knight really hasn't found a good home
has it well at least now it has the
opportunity perhaps to come to b6
and we've got uh maurice with some
thoughts on crush melakina is crush
wrapping this up
not at all she should have but because
of time pressure she has changed the
nature of the struggle from a clean win
to a you better find the right moves
situation it looks really like from
right here she was just in the driver's
seat
up up a material chasing the king queen
to c7 check king f6 and all she had to
do right now is just borrow this bishop
i mean borrow until the next game in
other words i'm going to keep your
bishop
but instead of doing that she played
the board is going ahead of me here
instead of taking on c5 here she played
queen d a check with only a minute on
her clock and then bishop e7 queen b6
check king to g7 and by now she'd
already blown it and she's played the
move rook to c1 and it looks like black
is winning now if black plays the move
d2 black is winning cold let's take a
look at at this analysis if melakina
finds this move before time control
there are some tactics going on on this
line the move being like where do you
put this rook let's put it on d1
suddenly knight takes on f3 check and
if bishop takes f3
this beautiful move
rook takes
takes and suddenly the attack is vicious
what can she do she's going to lose her
bishop she's going to lose her rook
likely she's under heavy pressure d2 is
winning for black in this moment if she
can find it
and it looks like she didn't find it she
played knight takes f3 bishop takes f3
instead but it's still equal rook takes
h3 now is just a draw rook takes gives
advantage to black as a matter of fact
so arena crush has ruined her position
and now has to play the right moves in
order to stay in the game she's still on
move is melahina needing to play rook h3
right now her clock ticking down she
still has to find the move but she has
two minutes and 22 seconds on her clock
so look at irina crush though must be
disgusted at herself that she's allowed
this and may have blown a full point a
chance to take a big lead you can see it
on her face looking where did i go wrong
but still rook h3 has to be found here
in and i don't think velocity is going
to miss this move rook h3 sitting on the
board are we anticipating that it should
happen at any moment and she will at
least have an equal position here at the
women's championships right so irina
actually got down to one second on her
clock no way one if she had just
stumbled for a second she would have
actually lost this game on time so
she is obviously was really worried um
and alyssa milikina now of course she
has to
to notice that you know her opponent may
move 40 but she hasn't and
you know will she be able to play or kh3
so i guess we should point out that the
difference here is in move order so what
happened
so no more win this win is gone
completely guys
wow
what a turnaround now that she's made
move forward and she has her time to
think about whether or not to go for the
perp or to go for more let me bring up
now what was the big difference in move
order here between playing knight takes
f3 immediately and playing d2 to start
because one of the ways that people
often mess up their tactics is by
screwing up the move order so irena
played rook to c
and now
d2 immediately is what maurice is saying
was a bone cruncher now the problem is
that after knight takes f3 bishop f3
d2 check doesn't transpose because of
queen to d4 jack i believe that's the
difference that goes down
so knight takes f3 so now d2 just runs
into queen g before exactly whereas
before there was a bishop in between
right so that's why d2 had to be played
immediately so move order of course with
minutes on both clocks
those types of subtleties are harder to
see so this was the with this and only
this was the moment to play the move d3
d2 and so in a way irena is lucky that
it was move 39 and not 41. because then
alyssa might have seen that and right it
would have been all tears um we've got
another player from the women's
championship with us tata abrahamian off
a great win and it'll also be really
exciting to hear what she thinks about
this
kind of scramble and the melakina crash
game absolutely
it's kind of reminiscent of yesterday
well it's just irina crush uh two little
game move 40 thrillers in a row right
right
well it goes to show how time trouble
makes a fool of us all indeed indeed
first of all let's congratul
congratulate tatev on her win today it
was a sparkling win not such hard work
at least
uh you're you're uh
thankful to win but what about this
crazy position have you been in time
pressure like this before where anything
could happen win lose win lose are all
the variations i think most of my kids
are like
indeed well this is not going to be a
win for for arena are you surprised by
the results here
um i mean i haven't been following the
game i just saw one moment of the game
like that arena was winning so i don't
know what happened
i was in time travel myself so i can
follow other games what do you think
about this time control with increments
uh does is it hard to judge
if you're in time pressure or not
considering you're going to get back 30
seconds on every move
um i have to increment because it's i
think it makes for better chess um but
it feels like you're always in time
travel maybe it's just me i have bad
time management but i always feel like
i'm in time travel but i like the
security of knowing if i make a couple
of fast moves i'll get my time back so
when i need to think that the critical
moments i know i have the opportunity to
do so indeed let's jump to your game
which is here
and your opponent
seemed to just collapse like from what
looked like a decent position
just fall apart with just a couple of
moves and all of a sudden you had a
vicious attack along the b1 h7 diagonal
right
yeah i don't know how that happened i
didn't think i had anything um actually
can i look at something sure of course
uh when she took here
yeah i was thinking what's the right
move here i was thinking knight c4
this position is supposed to be equal by
the way guys i hope we're not um
overlooking some drama happening in the
kowski game let me know if we need to
jump to that really quickly but uh let's
let's just go ahead here
they made move 40. okay yeah i was
thinking knight c4 and i i think we
might have miscalculated so if knight c4
takes 97 rookies knight to c4 new
variations
and takes here so take a 7
take
i was thinking knight d6 oh i guess
that's wrong
yeah i was thinking about this position
but that wasn't sure how there's a
slight edge for white after knight to b6
yeah but that wasn't very happy about my
d4 phone but the d4 pawn could end up
being away because queen e6 is a simple
defense here yeah so trade everything
take on a8 right yeah
and take here but then they can just no
no i have to take only six words oh
sorry
my fault sorry uh bishop takes
what happened we had a we had a mistake
they're taking now right right
all right and now king moves yeah so now
it takes
so you didn't like the d-pawn here the
weak d-pawn it looks like you don't have
much according to houdini as well but in
the position i also think i didn't have
much because her knights were nice on
the dark squares and my bishop i mean
kind of looked nice but i wasn't really
doing anything so the moment when you
queen d7 if you made move 21 uh
you're starting to get a slight edge
like somehow your bishop switches
diagonals yeah and now you got some
pressure
but even here i don't think i should
have anything very special
it doesn't look like it because her
nights are so nice like a night on
defense
yeah this was definitely a beautiful
piece but she let me trade bishop g5 i
think she didn't let me let me trade my
bad bishop i have the good bishop now
right in two more moves suddenly you
have coordinated all your pieces then
you made this nice move to trader chase
her knight but it looks like she could
have even taken on h3 now with check but
i like that position because now my
bishop's really open and her d night is
gone
oh i see so i thought that was good so
she dropped back and now the pressure
just
looked like it got to her in this
position you were able to attack and and
get this move off yeah so here i think
she has to go rookie eight actually
there's a variation of rookie eight we
trade everything queen he won king g2
there's 93 tiger king f3 okay that was a
little too fast
i followed you but i'm sure our audience
didn't so rookie 8
and trade everything trade trade
trade trade 96
take tank
and queen jakes yeah so it's just
queenie one king g2
knight e3 but i think i have king f3 and
i'm okay so the point and if capture is
then there's a perpetual check the queen
will just chase the king forever but
after king f3 and there's no knight d1
because bishop a2
so knight goes back and i'm up upon the
knight goes back you just move your
bishop somewhere you don't even have to
move
you could move anything i love the queen
so you were better in the position
anyway yeah i mean after ninety two i
think i'm better like rookie six and
everything so you're right now um you
are a point behind the leaders yeah so
with the win you've tied the leaders and
they're just they're trying to make sure
that they draw uh to well at least draw
because both of them are in trouble to
just just to stay ahead of you
so what's the what's your the remaining
field for you you've already played
both of them haven't you yeah so
it seems like you're in a good position
especially since they both have to play
each other at some point as well what
are your thoughts about the three rounds
remaining
oh well i have two blocks in the three
games and i don't know i think
it's i don't think anyone's playing
badly so i don't think i'm gonna have
any easy games
i guess they have harder opponents
because they have to play each other but
i got i played all the top players so i
have victoria astrid and i think camilla
left
so three of the lower rated players in
the competition puts you in a good place
uh to play the next three games
i mean i don't want to think about it in
those terms i mean like elisa okay she's
one of the bottom players right and
she's single against irena so you can
just say
you're not going to fall for my baits
basically exactly
well congratulations on your win we wish
you the best in the rest of the
tournament thank you
tatev
after a scintillating win
it looks to me like she's in a very good
position in the championships back to
you guys that's right maurice and uh you
know it is pretty rare that you get a
player to admit that their remaining um
opponents are weak
you know i remember
one rare exception which was actually
hilarious was in one of the early
championships here uh nakamura we had a
quad at the end so it was him and it was
ownership kamski him and yuri so yuri
was a little bit lower rated than the
other players but he was playing
fantastic chess and um we asked them all
about the lineup they're like just one
game at a time one game at a time every
game is going to be tough everybody's an
amazing player nakamura is just like
yuri's the weak point
and then
and then yuri won a beautiful game
against them stunning
never inspire your opponents by uh at
the same time it was fun for us that he
actually of course gave us an opinion
you know like it's okay you know
it's like
i think people know that it's not really
serious it's a post game interview it
doesn't mean that he hates you or
yourself of course not of course not no
but i always like i mean it wasn't to
everybody's style cass's claim muhammad
ali he was uh wonderful at um trash
talking if you will
and but he also followed it up right i
mean he would trash talk because i'm
gonna you know you're going down and ate
you know and stuff like that um well
nakamura and carlson got some trash
talking going on as well exactly exactly
it's good for the game
i'm still looking at the game of arena
for and i just wanted to show our
audience what we've been looking at over
here is if arena
obviously arena cannot capture with a
king let's start with that because of
our favorite checkmate
that's clear
and if arena dropped back with her king
well she's losing her bishop
thanks to the pin of the palm
oops
can't do that one so we've been looking
at
capturing the rook with the pawn
queen comes down with a check
and in this case
um alyssa has a perpetual check
obviously in the position
that after king
h2
does alyssa have more than a perpetual
check and that'll also depend on whether
irena has
a perpetual check or just a you know the
problem is like we would like to play
bishop h4 and get our bishop into the
attack but
then we're also opening up our own king
line with rook to c7 jack exactly
the black skin is vulnerable as well
so king h2
and this is the perpetual check that she
could do
is just going back and forth but also
i've been looking at a line that goes
like d2 rook g1 and oopsy daisy there's
this but hold on there's some there's
some tactics here still for example
queen
right
this was a nice one
and you can't take this queen because
i'll go check and take your rook however
after d2
i'm looking at this move queen d4 check
right
to be able to take with the
um
what should i do move the king or
to take like this
and
um
well what about uh earlier though
queen takes age three
okay so far mom was from the start right
queen g3 jack
king back queen takes h3 so now i'm
going to get on my high horse and try
now what's happening after queen to e3
check
queen e3 check okay
well i have to trade
and i better
bring my rook
ooh just a second you can see you could
play d2
and
and then after rookie 7e2
you know what they say about
two pawns in the sixth rank right
they're worth the rook two pawns on the
seventh rank worth of queen right
so some some uh interesting variations
here going on in crush melakina and uh i
think fresh was thinking actually
even though it's a forced move right
right or maybe
we'll keep a close eye on that but
meanwhile we have the other right arena
in the tournament irina zenyuk and she's
coming off a win and she's going to talk
to maurice ashley about her game and the
tournament itself
indeed jen we are with irina zenyak
first of all congratulations on your win
thank you must feel great to win but
irina
crush is one of your best friends so it
can't be great watching her suffer this
position especially since she was
winning before right i'm totally rooting
for arena and hoping like if i'm not
gonna win this championship i hope she's
gonna be the champion she wins all the
time though she's not even right
somebody else should get a chance
wow so good though she is a great friend
of yours we didn't get a chance to look
at your game quite honestly there were
so many games going crazy in fact so
many bad games in fact i mean when i say
bad i actually mean good because because
white played so crazy in a couple of the
games they just lost easily to the black
pieces
you might have gotten in some trouble
here with this knight sitting on b3 but
it looks like she didn't know how to
handle it properly exactly um she she
correctly put her knight on b3 and uh my
main strategic idea in this position is
to play b4 and with knight on b4 i want
to undermine it
and
potentially play b4 b5 creating a pass
pawn so knight b3 she prevented all of
this and um in this position i was
already
questioning what am i going to do next
so
possibly i can play knight b5 for
example
so her knight hangs and she will take i
will take on b3 but that position she
she if she has a lot of counter play
there it's equal and in fact your queen
seems like it's on the wrong side of
this knight on b3 as well yeah then my
queen is not doesn't feel too great
there and uh well i looked the possible
ways for her to trap my queen but i
couldn't find any so i was like okay
queen sits there let it be there and i
always have knight b5 but here she
played
she made a mistake yes this is uh
uh this is
no way she should allow me to push for
b4 and here um i i before right away it
doesn't quite work because she can take
and then take on c4 the c4 pawn hangs so
i thought okay uh
so i'll play bishop f1 here and i
thought
again she can play i think
since she she took she took the knight
away from v3 i thought psychologically
she's not going to put it back so uh
game there instead offered you a queen
trade which is already um gives me a big
plus after before
wow and after b5 the position is
crushing and i think
this is e5 this is already um well
taking b5 was another mistake uh
this is just gives me past pawn very
easy position to play exactly very easy
position to play very uh comfortable i
have bishop on g7 is not is out of play
her knight on d4 is beautifully placed
but it's more like a spectator i have my
my two bishops supporting the two pass
pawns this position it's a dream
position and your bishop which was bad
on this square suddenly woke up and has
this great square and right wow she did
manage to create some fireworks in there
let's let's move forward let's let's
fast forward a little bit uh
oh whoa night at five she tried exactly
so this is the
despera desperado but uh it was a time
scramble already we had each left about
three minutes here and i had to go for
this uh crazy line let's
scroll forward and uh d5 attacking her
of course you couldn't have taken her
night because of the pin on your king so
um now she's got two knights uh
connected in your position right but
often these nights don't make any sense
right yes yes but she had some some
pretty pretty intense idea so
bishop d3 uh so now i just want to win
second night and here she sacrificed
correctly the pawn d5 i took with the
pawn queen f6
now targeting my king suddenly um
i i thought i'm still one in here but it
was
very stressful scary moment exactly
instead you just took anywhere denied
and after check you just moved your
kingdom and then
she has to check on e2
and then here knight c3 and and i have
the only moon 91 king one because queen
h1 is a checkmate and here we had like
about half a minute a minute left each
and
and i was questioning whether i'm gonna
get checkmate in this position whether i
overlooked something but uh after kingi1
is just it seems like her attack
didn't really yeah she played e4
surely that was consolidated right
surely that was the best attempt i mean
i could have laundered something it's
just it's a purely um a purely practical
chance and she used it correctly so
that's uh it was interesting yeah but
now you're just up a rook
yes well she she did uh took one of the
rooks but that was over up a piece
another two points that's too much
that's definitely
well good win fighting win time pressure
everybody's getting in time pressure
exactly you know i i i see this this
increment do you like increments uh did
or do you find yourself getting in time
pressure because of them um well this is
i think this is the first game i got
into time time pressure because this is
the first game i tried to win really
hard i think
but uh i well uh honestly um i do like
increments i know you you maurice and
some other players uh think that we
should switch to delay which is okay not
as an option but uh
then the time scrambles that we will see
with delay it would be just
it's kind of funny because because i
remember back in the old days that we
didn't have either increments or delays
and we had time we did have time
scrambles of course but we never really
like i never really worried about this
problem you know it just seemed like it
was part of the game and we played and
we got to move 40 and it was just chess
it seems like when delay came or
increments and delays came people
thought
oh the old days
it must have been awful remember your
ass is like we didn't know how to manage
our time in the old days we always
gotten time pressure it was it wasn't
like that we just managed our time
properly i think the time pressure
addicts though love delays i mean love
increments exactly i don't have to face
that anymore and yet they still get into
trouble look at ray robson that doesn't
help him at all definitely benefits
those
people who get into time travel
regularly and they get benefit out of it
because they no longer no longer can
lose on time basically 30 seconds is
enough right
people who manage time well of course
delay for them would be better i think
because uh because then you have more
advantage against the other players
right that's to get into time travel
right absolutely it was part of the game
the clock but we'll see how things move
slowly in the chess world well
congratulations on the win on your
before your off day uh i'm sure you'll
sleep well tonight
i hope so good luck in the rest of the
championships irina zenyuk after a
dominant win
she's feeling good now back to you guys
and that brings her to three and a half
which
is a a pretty good position just a point
behind the leaders if zatonski or crush
manages to uh
draw their game so let's take a look at
irena's position after
kingdom g1
i'll bring that uh game of arena and the
two ladies boy they are intense aren't
they oh yeah they boy and the time
trouble time time control pardon me has
been already reached but neither of them
has really taken a break from the board
they were really uh studying
the position 30 minutes is going to go
by fast so what's the deal here after
queen to e3 chuck what's that how's this
plotting game looking i'm trying to
figure it out as well well after queen
e3 check
it's a it's a bizarre position
queen takes e3 what else right f takes
e3 now clearly black has just one goal
in mind just push the pawns make a queen
the problem i see it is that if king f1
trying to cozy up
uh to the e1 promotion square i don't
think you should play check right away
because there is a line of play
where i think you get the wrong
uh queen the wrong pro the wrong bishop
pardon me like this line is all wrong
for
for uh
for black black is not winning this
because if you took all of these pawns
off the board white can just make a draw
by bringing his king to the h1 square
but here's the one that
is having flummoxing me
is
this move for the moment bishop h4
oh darn it sometimes i'm i'm such an
idiot
i just play rookie one
i just play rookie one and
uh
i make a draw
that's not that idiotic yes that's a
pretty good move to see
not everybody sees moves like rookie one
and when they miss they call themselves
idiots so that's a that's a fine move
only move it looks like right in this
position although maybe rook
b2
will be yeah rook b2 seems like it
worked as well the road
right b2 would not work in this position
uh rook to rookie
definitely you know which has been seven
star moves so yeah it looks so that's
that's a good move i mean the these
incredibly frightening looking pawns on
d3 and e3 white's king is just in time
you can't play d2 is just a dream but
the problem is that after the rook moves
the king will come and blockade and that
will be all she wrote so i think the
move king f1 is saving arena
because she can follow it up
pardon me follow it up with the move
rookie one and be prepared to sacrifice
her rook for the two
past black pawns and get the bishop and
wrong color um rook pawn
and when irina took a deep thing maybe
she was looking at some of these
variations making sure that she had some
hope well exactly because she just
really went through a shock turn around
in this game she was cruising to victory
time trouble
uh blunders
and suddenly bang at the end of the time
control this move rook takes h3 if you
didn't see that move before it must have
been a real shock to arena system
because now she had to recalibrate and
say instead of saying oh i've got this
game in the bag i'm winning i'm winning
oh please don't tell me i'm lost
that's right so we'll keep it high on
that and see whether this is a alyssa in
a deep thought about whether to play
queen e3 check or i'm not sure what else
to play though if she just goes back to
g3
you know irena can now start
yeah actually queen g3 check is also an
interesting point maybe she's
considering that with the idea of
snapping the pawn on h3 and seeing how
that goes
but meanwhile in gada kemp's key lender
man
and i was just actually going to a
different game i was going to the other
co-leader i think var er kobien
against ray robson ray robson down upon
and var is settling in very very nicely
i think he's well on his way
to
would this be his third win on the truck
third winner five girls starting with
four draws and three wins wow very
impressive so what we see in this
position is black's minor pieces are
coming alive
all of his pieces in fact are focused on
this f4 square so
this is very nice he's an extra pawn up
active queen this bishop on g2
is a good defensive piece but there's
nothing on this diagonal and so
right now i think that
var
he hasn't chalked up the point don't get
me wrong but he's well on his way to
winning this game he's got all the
trumps the
beautiful f4 square the safe king and
the extra pawn right so this is going to
be a tough task for ray to save
exactly moving on to our other
co-leaders game uh
in the open section
um
godakamski has
kept his extra pawn we're going to go
back these were these moves were quickly
played just before the time control so a
mixture of maybe second best and good
moves
but basically what happened is
gotta traded off
his b5 pawn for black's pawn on a3
at the moment he's got a problem with
his bishop but let's see how ghada
handled that he brought his bishop back
to f1
always this pawn on h6 is like this
this bone in your throat you're trying
to clear
the situation for this
black king but this pawn on h6
is really an annoying annoyance
now look at this god has got an
active rook this is the first time in
the game that his rook has actually been
great
and